Okay, so the first module that I'm sharing with you here is truly understanding
this
tool here and the power and the feature of it.
And so on here you'll see two things, when you're looking at the 15 minute
timeframe
especially, you'll see directional bias and you'll see market structure.
Now on one hand, it's easy to get a little bit confused on what the actual
difference
between the two is.
I mean, isn't directional bias the same as market structure, don't you derive
your
directional bias based off of market structure?
And potentially yes, unless you know something that I'm going to share with you
now.
So in this case, we have a weekly and we have a daily directional bias.
And you can see here that actually both of them are bearish, but the 15 minute
and for
our timeframe are actually bullish in terms of their actual structure.
As you can see, you know, swing low, change of character, swing high.
And also I'm in a short position literally right now that I've recently closed
partials
of these lows in.
So structure is bullish, but I'm sure in the daily bias and the weekly bias is
bearish.
And also on my live trading sessions yesterday with my live trading students
and some of
the innocent and actually some of the prosperity school members, I'm telling
them literally
yesterday that this is the level that I'm expecting a lot of prices from.
Now, why?
Why is that?
That's what I kind of want to share with you today.
And that's kind of what the buy the daily bias the weekly bias is about.
So I'm going to insert a full kind of like 15 minute video that I've created
for you
on the daily bias that just basically explains what it is in a very simple
shell.
The daily bias is really simple, it's based off of the logic that if today's
daily candle
closes below the previous day's candle, the next day's price action is going to
be bearish.
And this isn't random opinion.
In fact, let me back it up with the data.
So this is for 2721 days in which there was an actual bearish close.
And this data that I have collected here is over 5,469 days.
And so what is that 5,469 divided by 365?
So this is actually over 15 years of data.
And so as you can see, we don't play around around here.
We're not the type of people that are going to give you some vague nonsense and
claim
that it works.
Now, this is 15 years of historical data that we have proven this.
And what we have found is that on 67% of the time in which the current days
candle closes
below the previous day's low, the next day trades bearish below the previous
day's low.
And so if you look, for example, let's go to the daily right now and kind of
just explain
this, right?
So what we can see is in theory what this would indicate, so we can come out of
replay
for a second.
Well, this specific concept would indicate that this day's candle closed below
the previous
days low, correct?
And so we are indicating that the next day will be a bearish day that trades
below this
low down here.
Now there's also more power to this when you understand that before it does
that, what
we're looking for is a retracement and then the sell-off.
And so if you put the next day, you can see we open, we trade higher and then
we trade
lower, perfect sell-off opportunities.
So that's that specific one.
And there are a bunch of different logic, right?
So for example, if and the reason that it says on our indicator why we are bear
ish today,
right? That is because if price wicks above the previous days high, wicks above
the previous
days high and closes inside of that range, there is, again, a 67% likelihood
that price
will trade down into the low of that day and you come into today.
And so already I have been in shorts or been looking at shorts from this area
of price.
Right?
Which is why if you look at where I am, I am already in shorts from here.
This is my London setup, which is also, again, like I said, a lot of the
members are in this
exact trade as well.
And I'm holding some partial down to this low.
So that's just one of the points of logic.
There is a lot more than that, right?
It also indicates, again, so this is daily wins.
So it also indicates the opposite, which is if we close above on the daily, we
are expecting
the next day. So again, 67% accuracy.
So this is true with a 67% accuracy of the last 50 years of price.
Also the exact same thing happens for the weekly, right?
The weekly also has the same thing.
We have noticed that there is actually a 68% level of accuracy with on the
weekly.
So the exact same thing, if we look at the weekly, right, the exact same thing.
So you can see right here, right?
This is the previous week's candle.
This previous week's candle has closed below this candle.
And so coming into this week, the expectation for price has been we will open,
we will trade
higher, and then we will trade lower.
And the target that we should expect with a 68% likelihood over the period of
many, many,
many years, that's a 68% likelihood, which is a very high probability that that
's going
to play out.
And so I'm going to add in now a little bit of a snippet that will take this a
little
bit further so you can see it really kind of play out in action on how I'm
reading this.
And yeah, that is what this is.
So when you're in price and you see that the market structure direction is one
thing.
So it will show you the market structure direction is on the 15 minute is
bullish and the four
hour is bullish, but both the daily and weekly directional biases are both bear
ish, right?
And so you can kind of get where I'm going with this.
This is one of the invalidation methods of structure sometimes, which I'll
break down
later.
So I'll give you a little bit more context now into kind of how that works and
I'll show
you it in action working really well.
And that should conclude this.
And you shall proceed to do with this information as you deem necessary.